all right um let's try Eve for the
French let's try the anti French are
they in pre-move mode it's not a good
choice I don't really know if that's the
name this is actually it's the chigorin
variation CH IG Oh Rin if you're curious
about looking it up that name is
unfamiliar to you could I just gain some
space here G for it seems a bit
ridiculous but somehow I might want to
do it now I don't want to do that let me
do something less committal how about
just throw another pawn in the center
what's wrong with that
is this move gonna come you know yeah
let me do I'm gonna go for like a Kings
Indian structure so let me do this to
start I was just gonna do g3 it's almost
like I'd be I'm going against my own
words from a previous game but do note
that in that in that previous game I was
talking about how you want to be able to
reinforce your Center and avoid the
Queen exchange I'm avoiding the Queen
exchange I do have this Center
reinforced and now that this pond is
pushed maybe I can do this instead and
then follow up with f4 and then night
here I think I might like that idea
or maybe f4 right now yeah that's better
yeah I'm gonna try this f4 Knight f3 g3
Bishop g2 and this is like birds and
birds opening I pretty much want to keep
these guys right where they're at
side by side keep them as a duo and well
why don't why do I want to do that well
for as long as I do that I retain
flexibility between them maybe this
maybe this maybe capture and well maybe
I'm not liking Knight here is that gonna
be a pain maybe
how about this move maybe now I could
change the structure ah what's the big
difference now I'm gonna do that rules
out me having to worry about night here
additionally what is it that black wants
to do with this now struck with this
structural change what direction they go
they play on the queenside this pond
would like to get rolling but guess
who's in the way so maybe this is going
to be a bit of an inconvenience now I
could throw my night out right away but
maybe I want to get in something like c3
d4 no I don't want to give this bishop
the opportunity for maybe taking my
knight and then giving a check with the
Queen with this is good enough actually
my knight here is already threatening d4
so let me focus more on development here
however right now since I have a space
advantage I want to be cautious about
trading too much maybe there was an
opportunity to get a pair of Knights off
with Knight here and c3 is well now I
could play this and then get my light
square bishop on d3 yeah let's do that
my bishop needs to come out or should it
come out how do I organize the rest of
my development here hmm clean here
bishop here and then castle Queen here
eventually if the C file opens up I'm
not going to be too happy about having
my queen on c2 and if I try and develop
my bishop in this direction there could
be a five bishop here so let's not do
that we go with this
maybe Queen g3 later yeah this is this
is a decent idea Queen g3 Queen d3 okay
I don't know that that's a good choice
here just gonna develop now maybe I
could even prevent the light-square
bishop exchange keep in mind this is a
bad guy and now okay let me get more
development in I'm gonna look to get in
c4 it's a plan that I now have so Knight
B to d2 okay and I don't I want to make
black struggle a bit more to get the
LightScribe bishops off I guess they can
really force it if then that comes back
here but I'm gonna I'm gonna be a pest
too black if they do that my idea here
is going to be okay well they're not
threatening that yet but I'm still gonna
do this move just to prevent the pawn
push because I think if it happens it's
a gaining space in the Queen side and it
also allowing for Knight a5 to b4 c4
ideas I don't see a good reason not to
play Knight here however maybe I want to
get my knight to this Square and if you
ever kicked away I could play here maybe
give up a pawn just to cement a knight
on this square I do however need to be
moving much quicker than I am
let's play my knight here instead or
yeah let's go here I have a space
advantage maybe just not even allowed
bishop for Knight exchange I do have to
go quicker i opponent i already know to
be fast so King side castle
this Knight I could be pinning it but I
don't know what the follow-up is after
just the breaking of the pin in fact I
see it more of a case of me putting my
bishop in a spot where it's welcoming a
light square bishop exchange and clearly
that's something I do not want to do
it's it's for that reason I played Queen
e2 earlier it's no one the times are
evening out castles for some reason I
kept thinking like is Knight b8 Bishop
a6 a nice try keep in mind these
maneuvering type of things can come
about look how the center is closed so
there is there is time for these sorts
of things and okay well we're gonna have
a pair of Knights coming off and now
this other one could follow in place
here and I'm gonna run forward there's
rook g1 pawn push however with this last
move that is different well
let's see I want to get dark square
Bishop saw fits my opponent can allow me
to do that pawn push here these guys are
kind of stuck okay basically let's stop
that guy right in his tracks mm-hmm okay
well
kind of helping them out not the bishop
pair so what so who cares about that
bishop pair maybe I want to be in a
quick spot to get in c4 and open up the
position as soon as this Knight moves
and is no longer around to jump into the
week and be Foursquare maybe right now I
do it in fact let's go in this direction
right now want to open it up over here
time time time we go with this just open
it up let's just open this up I gotta
watch out for me
devote a rope to it I want to keep this
pawn right here for a moment my queen I
think could be very annoying if she
could get here we threaten mate first
main threat
we could take here and for both of my
rooks I think this is now serious
trouble where's the king go I think I
get a like first strike here I land the
first significant blow it's got really
opposite sides cast and we both went
after one another's Kings here leave I
could do this first and then throw in a
check
and now just recapture no that's just me
alright mister and Alan chess good game
I think that's one of the first ones
that really went down to the water like
that we've played several games few did
not know those that are viewing this
myself in Alan chess have played several
so okay how did things look from your
perspective here keep in mind well how
can you how can you um do something
different maybe ah right here maybe
doing something like Bishop e7 and then
c5 Knight c6 is a better way to
reorganize stuff my opponent is saying
that Queen e2 is new to you yeah it's
definitely a typical so if you're a
French player and you're seeing Queen e2
this is pretty much stopping the d5
advance cuz you're not able to recapture
with your epon anymore because of the
pin so maybe even here Bishop e7 with
this move throw a question of my pawn
quickly and then maybe get in depending
on what he does get in c5 I think things
are a bit awkward for you when you play
your Bishop to c5 as aggressive looking
as it is it does allow for me to gain
tempo and with the structural change
this Bishop is now misplaced he's in the
way of your C pond it's it's this guy
that wants to be on c5 and then the
knife kind of just tucking himself right
behind it on c6
okay so anyhow that's an important
detail because it does translate to a
different structure and there's all of a
sudden a clock ticking on you know who
could maybe build up the center are you
in a spot too quickly maybe try and rip
it down so yeah he's kind of just backed
up now the other thought I had for you
at this point right here well I don't
know about the pawn push for one maybe
maybe you should do a now-or-never thing
like right now why don't you do f5 and
just give me the one opportunity are you
gonna take right now are you gonna keep
it closed
instead of baby stepping it with the the
two moves so maybe that's an adjustment
as well but even working with this
position right here I like this idea
trying to get the LightScribe bishops
off I believe that was your intention
and now right here maybe maybe it is in
this direction you could be going with
your knight get rid of my number one
attacking piece my are my let's say my
good bishop for your bad bishop try and
get that exchange in it seems awkward
but again the center is closed and I
think you could maybe afford the time to
do just that now which Knight to do that
with and that's oh sure
maybe there's a reason to run with the
knight on C so that if this pond comes
under fire you have your C pond around
to support it it's tough in fact excuse
me sorry about that it's a tough call
but or actually I'm liking this better
actually if you go at this night if I'm
ever thinking about c4 you have night
moves to b4 so maybe this is a better
try and i b8 with Bishop a6 to follow a
small a small middle game plan to try
and implement these aren't like what
would you call it these aren't like
super elaborate plans it's like okay how
can I just recognize which are the good
bishops which are the bad how can i
maybe get my bad bishop for their good
Bishop exchange this is maybe a way you
can do just that
but the game went into a much different
direction and yeah I don't know about
the decision to castle so quickly but I
don't know an interesting interesting
game right there
down upon but hardly matters in these
cases with opposite sides castling yeah
this is tough I don't know that this is
defendable here yeah I think I'm we're
beyond the point of it being defendable
once the queen is sneaking in here but
okay good game